okay he's
back
okay hey what's going on there's a
police car in them what
oh what's going on oh pH guy flashed
it's
um I don't think laughing about it a pro
great response oh come on we laughing at
Phyllis but she's not even here so no
harm no foul I don't think the women in
the SAU incidentally where were you
during all of this maybe you're the
Flasher I was at a parent teacher
conference uh-huh prove it let's see
your
penis I you
know as that was coming out of
myab
baby
back I want my baby back baby back baby
back I want my
chili baby back
ribs
Chili's Chili's baby back
ribs no wait out second one
okay phis is only pretending to be a man
I'm the real thing sit down on my lap
and there will be no doubt okay no it's
not it's not like penis wise hello
little boy what's your name Michael it's
me Kevin Phyllis says I'm too big for
her lap oh I am so sorry that Phyllis
hates you and hates your body but Santa
remembers a reindeer that was just a
tiny bit different as well when can I
sit on your lap right now come on over
here big
boy there we go oh my
God that's really
comfortable what would you like a
Christmas little
boy I don't know I I didn't know you
were going to ask me that what did you
think was going to happen I didn't know
nobody's ever let me sit on their lap
before say some toys please can you give
me some choices cuz I really don't want
to mess up on this list damn it Kevin
come on what about if I tell you the
things I don't want okay get off get
off oh god I didn't even get to tell you
what I wanted okay you know what you get
you got a th helium balloons attached to
you so Santa doesn't have to go through
this
again awesome can sit on your lap now
you can sit on my lap all you want
because I I am a male Santa and that is
something that Phyllis cannot do oh my
God okay this is really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little
boy I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys can can you give me some choices oh
my God Kevin please sorry
copper squat here we
go
sorry squat I'm glad what would you like
for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here
sorry
sh all right who did this I'm not mad I
just want to know who did it so I can
punish them what are you talking about
uh someone uh forged medical information
and that is a felony okay whoa all right
cuz that's a pretty intense accusation
how do you know that they're fake uh
leprosy flesh eating
bacteria hot dog
fingers government created killer nanor
B
infection you did this didn't you
absolutely not yes you did know I didn't
I know it was you okay fine you know
what I'm going to have to interview each
and every one of you until the
perpetrator makes him or herself known
and until that time there will be no
healthc care coverage for
anyone now I know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what that is a risk
we have
to that
is
that is a risk that we have to no no no
I know what you're saying why do you
keep
going hey I know what you're thinking
won't that just
shed I know what you're thinking won't
that just shed more light on the penises
but that is a risk we need to take Pam
thank you Pam why don't you work with
palas and draw a picture of the
exposer don't confence room is ready if
we want to get started you know I just
want to address everyone first oh yeah
take your time Stanley pay attention
hi everyone Hi hi uh look it's no secret
hi hello uh it is no secret that Michael
Scott paper has siphoned off a large
chunk of our Core Business and I'm here
I just want to reassure everyone that we
think this is just a temporary setback
we have three sex or or heavy petting
closets one masturbation closet does
anyone have a problem with that yes gay
closet five that was no that's that that
wasn't the problem three heavy petting
closets one masturbation closet and one
gay closet absolutely I problem
everybody happy with the glory hole what
well I heard about it somewh holy fifth
closet will have a glory
hole I don't get the big fuss here I
like the site if I had created a website
with this many problems I'd kill myself
do you have a question Kelly yeah I have
a lot of questions number one how dare
you Ryan is doing a very good job and I
am not applauding sarcastically think
about it a month ago nobody would go on
this site because we're worried about
getting molested or losing our identity
having it stolen but now at a time
tdb all of these problems will be in the
past you're doing good kid you're doing
good
well hello
everybody
hello oh
man I'm prison
Mike you know why they call me prison
Mike do you really expect us to believe
you're somebody else do you really
expect me to not push you up against the
wall
Beach all right hey hey hey hey that's
just the way we talk in the clink been a
lot of fun talk about prison today but I
am here to scare you
straight I am in ESC
stre in prison you are somebody's
oh and you you my friend would be
the bell of the ball don't don't drop
the soap don't drop the soap Michael
please where did you learn all of this
internet so not prison and prison at
50/50 B look prison stinks is what I'm
saying it's not like you can go home and
recharge your batteries and come back in
the morning and be with your friends
having fun in the
office what' you do prison Mike I stole
and I
robbed and I kidnapped the president's
son and held him for
ranom that is quite the rap sheet prison
Mike and I never got caught neither well
you're in prison but mhm prison Mike
what was the food like in prison GRL
sandwiches GRL omelets nothing but GRL
plus you can eat your own hair wow
prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you we and D thanks prison Mike
what's the very very worst thing about
prison don't encourage him the worst
thing about prison was the was the
Dementors they were flying all over the
place and they were scary and then they
come down and they suck the soul out of
your body and it height de dementor like
in Harry Potter no not Harry Potter
there are no movies in prison when it
came out for soccer
practice I I pinched him
where did you pinch
him